في بدايه مايو من هذا العام هاجم الطائرات
مسيره مبنى الكرملين وسط موسكو استنفرت
القوات الروسيه وسرع الرئيس الاوكراني
لا نهاجم بوتين او موسكو نحن نحارب في
ارضنا وندافع عن وطننا
هذه المره لا شيء يمكن اخفاؤه او نثيره
موسكو تحت القصف
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه قالت انها تحتفظ
بحق الرد بينما خرج الرئيس الروسي هادئا
يتحدث عن تعزيز دفاعات حول العاصمه
موسكو المضاده للصواريخ عملت كما ينبغي
رغم ان هناك اشياء يجب تحسينها لقد واجهنا
بالفعل نفس المشكله في قاعده حميم الجويه
في سوريا على الرغم من انه لا يمكنك
مقارنه قاعدتنا الجويه في حميم بموسكو هذه
مدينه اوروبيه ضخمه لكن بشكل عام نحن نفهم
ما يتعين علينا القيام به لتعزيز نظام
عاصمتنا المضاد للصواريخ وسنفعل ذلك
دول اوروبيه انتشر الدفع لثاني اقوى قوه
عسكريه في العالم مؤكده ان ما تقدمه من
اسلحه ليكياف مخصص لدفاع وليس لنقل
المعركه داخل روسيا
اخر مره تعرضت فيها موسكو لقصف حقيقي كان
في اربعينيات القرن الماضي خلال الحرب
العالميه الثانيه بينما تعرضت نيويورك
لقصف بالطائرات في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر
عام 2001 ردت عليها الولايات المتحده
بحروب قتل فيها اكثر من خمسه ملايين انسان
اعطي المزيد
نظريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على
اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات